ABC News and WM have cancelled the next
GOP Presidential primary debate after
only Ron de santis agreed to show up
four candidates Trump Haley DeSantis and
Chris Christie remember him they
qualified for the debate chrisy has
already dropped out now Nikki Haley is
refusing to debate unless Trump shows up
which he's not going to do because he
hasn't gone to any of them because he's
leading the pack by just under 50 points
nationally Haley is smart not to debate
only D santis because debates are always
a risk and she has nothing to gain Nikki
Haley is currently leading to santis in
the next state New Hampshire by almost
23 points the numbers are 23 point I'm
sorry
29.3% to 65% for disantis a debate
before New Hampshire would be all
downside for Haley with no upside Haley
also has no incentive to debate before
the following State Nevada because she
is not even competing there a few years
ago Nevada legislators moved to replace
the state's caucus system which is
similar to what we saw last night in
Iowa with a primary system which is more
in line with what the rest of the
country does the Nevada GOP opposed the
move so it's holding a caucus anyway and
says that anyone who participates in the
primary can't participate in the caucus
but while all the rest of the GOP
candidates opted for the GOP run caucus
Nikki sided with the state and filed for
the primary so doesn't even matter to
her and Trump is currently polling at
69% there nice so doesn't matter anyway
next up is South Carolina that's
obviously Haley's home state where she
is currently in second with double the
support that DeSantis has so no reason
for her to debate before that one and
then finally there's Michigan where
DeSantis has a slight lead over Haley
but it's doubtful that the governor will
even still be in the race at that point
and even if he is Trump currently has
over 61% support in Michigan that's all
before super Tuesday when 16 States and
territories will vote most if not all of
which are certain to go to Trump all of
which is to say we're not getting an ABC
News debate before New Hampshire and
we're probably not getting a CNN debate
either and we're probably just not
getting any more debates at all because
the 2024 GOP Primary is for all intents
and purposes over I'm Michael nolles
this is the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show Breaking News a
porn actress Mia Khalifa was insulted in
public she's gone viral for this she
usually goes viral for uh promoting
the Palestine Liberation movement and
supporting terrorists and things like
that but she's gone viral here for a
different reason shockingly she was
insulted in public we'll get to that
very important story in just a moment
first
though the fact that the political media
are still reporting on the primary as
though it were some hot contentious
thing is
crazy I'm happy to talk about the
primary a little bit because it does
matter matter who the nominee is and
who's going to be the next president and
whether or not we're going to send the
next nominee of the Republican party to
prison and whether we're going to fall
into Civil War and whether the American
Republic is going to cease to exist and
all of that stuff matters but most of
the political media are still reporting
on this GOP Primary as
though it could go another way it can't
unless a bolt of lightning comes out of
the sky or out of
the hands of a Democrat it's over it's
Trump but here's how they're reporting
on it the libs and and some places on
the right even are trying to suggest
that Trump's win in Iowa doesn't mean
all that much and and what they point to
is they say there was low turnout in
Iowa only something like 110,000 people
caucused that was down from an all-time
high back in 2016 that I think was
around 170 or 80,000 people caucusing so
they're saying only only
14% of of the Ians came out and only
half of them voted for Trump so it's not
really a big
victory and 14% is a pretty low number
sure
but I don't think it's really a knock on
Trump I think it's probably more a knock
on the other
campaigns Trump already seemed to have
the state locked up also it was 9°
outside so the fact that anyone showed
up at all is pretty impressive negative
9 degrees is bad it's currently 10
degrees here in Nashville and we're
still not allowed to go back to work at
Daily wire because there's a little bit
of snow on the ground and the whole city
has shut down so Nega 9 degrees that's
pretty intense and more to the point
people are not really that incentivized
to vote if they think that the thing is
already done Trump was pulling at 52% in
Iowa before the caucuses so the
incentive for anyone to show up for a
trump voter certainly or even some of
the the supporters of the other
campaigns is going to be greatly
diminished this was the story in 2016 do
you remember the Democrats said well the
reason Trump won in 2016 is because
everyone thought Hillary was going to
win so the Democrats thought that they
didn't have to go vote and Democrats who
would have supported Hillary stayed home
because they thought there was there was
no reason to to do it and then the
Republicans were more motivated and the
Republicans won so using that logic then
then what that would suggest is
the other candidates would have had much
more of an incentive to show up the fact
that the the turnout was low is actually
a knock on the other campaigns for not
getting out the vote because the the the
Trump supporters would have already
thought that they had it in the bag if
you're going to compare it to something
like
2016 but I I think probably what
happened is that a lot of GOP voters one
didn't want to go out and freeze but a
lot of GOP voters are treating this as
though the primary is just fake that
it's a fat comp it's it's been done from
the
beginning as some of us perhaps
predicted early on you know I hate to
say I told you
so I think a lot of GOP voters are just
treating Trump as the incumbent in this
primary and that's how it turned out
last night in Iowa all of the other
candidates could have Consolidated
around one one anti-trump candidate
every single campaign just put all their
resources all their voters all their
money put it together gone up against
Trump trump still would have won Iowa
last night and I'm not saying it's good
I'm not saying it's bad I'm not saying
anything about who should
win I'm just saying the guy is basically
an incumbent and the polls were proven
correct in Iowa which to me implies that
the polls are likely to be about right
in the other states which implies that
the primary is over so now we turn our
attention away from the GOP infighting
and we focus our attention on beating
the left and there's a CLI clip of a
very prominent left Winger that is going
around now Bernie Sanders Bernie the
leader of the Socialist wing of the
Democrat Party at least for decades now
maybe some of the Young Guns and and the
squad are taking that position from him
but still he's probably the most
prominent socialist on the left and the
clip is going viral because Bill Maher
tricked him in a debate over equality
versus equity Equity you've got that
equality which a lot of people agree
with versus this new leftist socialist
view of equity you know which is which
is everyone having the same outcomes not
just the same opportunity and even that
socialist Bernie Sanders said that he
supports
equality Dei are we confusing equality
of opportunity with trying to guarantee
equity and outcomes okay that's
interesting because I think this word
Equity has come into the language in the
last few years years and before that we
didn't hear it a lot and I think a lot
of people hear equity and they hear
equality that it's the same word and
it's not the same word and the same
concept so how would you differentiate
between equity and
equality well equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
come me to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it
not I think so I think that's okay so
which do you come which side do you come
down on uh equality equality yeah
okay
haha they got him that liberal is a
classical liberal though Bill Maher you
know he's the good kind of liberal Bill
Maher he supports equality a lot of
people support equality of opportunity
but Bernie is a socialist supposed to
support Equity equality of outcome but
but even Bernie even a radical Like
Bernie says that's too much and so those
Dei people those woke people the squad
the ones arguing for Equity therefore
meaning equality of oper of of outcome
rather they're they're crazy and you
know what I
say I actually don't think there's much
difference between the two which we'll
get to in one second first though when
we're talking about our economy we got
to talk about ramp right now go to
ramp.com
when you are running a business time is
money that is why I am so excited to
have ramp as a new sponsor on the show
if you're a finance professional looking
for a better way to maximize
productivity and cut wasteful spending
than ramp could be for you ramp is the
corporate card and spend management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back in your pocket with a
ramp you can issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
automate expense reporting and stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramp's accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so you don't have
to you will never have to chase down a
receipt again and your employees will no
longer spend hours submitting expense
reports the time that you'll save each
month on employee expenses will allow
you to close your books eight times
faster ramp is easy to use get started
in less than 15 minutes whether you have
five employees or 5,000 get 250 bucks
when you join ramp go to ramp.com
kwes that is rm.com /n kwes that is
ramp.com
kwl cards issued by Sutton Bank and
Celtic Bank members FDIC terms and
conditions apply the conservatives we
support equality of opportunity it's
those crazy leftists they support Equity
by which they mean equality of
outcome I don't think those are actually
opposites I don't think that's much of a
debate at all
I actually think they're kind of the
same thing
ultimately it's a it's a battle between
liberalism and
communism and in recent decades the
conservatives have made common cause
with the Liberals some have gone so far
as to say that we conservatives were the
true liberals or we're the classical
liberals or whatever I'm not a liberal
I'm not a modern liberal I'm not an old
liberal I'm not a middle ground liberal
I'm not a liberal I don't I don't
believe in
liberalism so I don't I'm certainly not
a communist so I actually think they're
both kind of wrong I think equality of
opportunity and equality of outcome
they're both just fantasies and they're
both ultimately
wrong I want people
to have their just doe I want people to
have every good opportunity they
possibly can have but there's no such
thing as equality of opportun
some people are born a little smarter
than
others and it's and there're people who
are born with a high IQ who squander
their natural advantages and totally
neglect their education and they might
end up worse off than someone who's
maybe born with a little bit of a lower
IQ but they work really hard and they're
really diligent they cultivate good
habits that that's certainly
true but they still started from a
different
place there is no actual equality of
opportunity
let's talk about something that might be
more important than
IQ having two parents who are married to
one another in a loving stable
household not everyone gets
that equality of opportunity what are we
going to do how are we going to level
out that playing field there are a lot
of people who are born at a wedlock who
are born with absent fathers who are
born in bad family circumstances who are
born without a mother or father Maybe
it's two fathers three fathers now five
fathers in a billy goat
whatever they're suffering from a
natural
disadvantage compared to someone who's
born to a loving mother and father
married in a stable household what are
we going to do are we going to in order
to level that playing field so everyone
has the same equality of opportunity are
we going to break up the stable marriage
and probably the left would like to do
that now no that doesn't seem like a
good idea are we going to force the the
couple that had the kid out of wedlock
to get married I would be fine with that
but the Liberals the classical and
otherwise who push for equality of
opportunity they're not going to do that
there's no one's calling for that it's
just a a natural
disadvantage some of these are are more
socially constructed some of these are
just natural like IQ so what are we
going to do then well what's going to
happen is because equality of
opportunity is a fantasy that can never
exist in real life then there are going
to be inequalities that persist equality
of opportunity is going to be shown to
be a failure and then guess what's going
to happen people are going to demand
Equity they're going to demand equality
of outcome because equality of
opportunity is an impossibility and
they're going to be right when they when
they point to that but equality of
outcome what that's just communism
that's not going to work either that's
going to be a monstrosity that's going
to be a terrible
Injustice so then what do we really
want we don't want equality or equity in
the liberal sense of the term I mean for
goodness mes equality is part of the
motto of the French
Revolution
liberal fraternity or you know Li
Liberty equality and fraternity or death
and then they Lop off everybody's heads
that's that's extreme liberalism that's
that's not we don't want either of those
things the the true equality that exists
is a spiritual equality before God
because there is no neither Jew nor
Greek nor slave nor free nor male nor
female but all are one in Christ Jesus
that's a true equality and equality
before God because there is human
solidarity we all descend from a common
ancestor We Are All Made in the image
and likeness of God and we are Redeemed
by the very same God the only begotten
Son of God who comes down to earth God
sends his son to die so that whoever
believes in him might not perish but
have eternal life that's true
equality it it's an equality of
opportunity for everlasting life it is
not an equality of opportunity for
everyone to go become a CEO someday
anyone can be president anyone can be an
astronaut it's not true I'm not going to
be a basketball player I never really
wanted to be a basketball player and I
won't be one and I never had a chance to
be one it drives me crazy no it doesn't
drive me crazy but that's just my my
state in life the conservative view is
not the liberal View and it's not the
Communist
view it it's a view that respects
natural limits and is diligent and
pursues good and wants all sorts of good
stuff but recognizes that there are
natural limits and there are natural
inequalities in the world and we can
either bury our heads in the sand we can
deny that but when you deny truth when
you deny reality it just leads to more
radicalization the the liberal
liberalism is going to lead to Communism
in fact that's exactly what happened in
the history of ideology and the history
of politics so if you if you want to
avoid that it's much better to Ally
yourself with reality and with the truth
equality before God is a good thing it's
much more important now speaking of God
Mr Mead Rob Reiner most famous for one
having a very famous and talented father
in Hollywood and two playing a guy named
Meathead on All in the Family one of the
great sitcoms of all time Rob Riner
who's a big lib has just come out and
he's asked how a Christian could
possibly vote for
Trump rer says Jesus told us to do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you how in God's name can anyone who
believes in the teachings of Jesus
support Donald Trump we hear this line
all the time we it's Rob Riner is not
the first guy to bring it up you hear it
all the
time but what is he really
asking is is Rob Riner and all these
libs are they asking how a Christian can
vote for a sinner are they saying that
Donald Trump fails to live up to the
Christian ideal of Life he's a sinner
and so therefore you can't vote for him
well that doesn't make a lot of sense
the the central Insight of the Christian
is that we're all Sinners all have
sinned and fallen short of the glory of
God and therefore we're not going to
save ourselves and we're in need of a
savior not a political savior either
it's kind of nice to have good
politicians every now and again but we
need a savior who is not just king of a
country but King of the whole
universe that doesn't make sense we
can't vote for Sinners we can't vote for
anybody but does Rob Riner
mean how can a Christian vote for a
non-Christian is he not just saying that
Trump he's a Christian but he's a sinner
but he's saying Trump isn't a real
Christian he's not a Christian at all so
how can a Christian vote for a
non-Christian I don't know Rob Riner is
not a Christian that mean we can't vote
for him the vras Swami is not a
Christian that means we can't vote for
him
we we in our very
Constitution learn that there is no
religious test for public
office is he going to throw that out the
window I don't know that's pretty
extreme Rob Reiner is saying he should
only vote for Christians I mean it' be
not be good to have a a more uh
Christian informed government I'm all
for that but that that seems pretty
extem is Rob Riner a Christian
nationalist now I don't think so now you
know what I think he is is I think he's
engaging in a typical leftist tactic
from Saul Alinsky he probably doesn't
even know he's doing this but it just
comes as second nature to the libs he is
forcing his opponent to live according
to their own principles and their own
ideals principles and ideals that they
would
never cause themselves to live up
to and that's a very effective tactic
but in this case it's totally incoherent
because he is insinuating that
Christians should live up to ideals and
principles that are not intrinsically
Christian it's just totally bogus in
this case it can be very very effective
when the libs and the Alinsky ites do
this but it's just not effective in this
case there is no Christian principle
that says you can't vote for a sinner we
wouldn't have a government
anymore can't vote for a sinner you
can't vote for a non-Christian all right
who are we going to vote for I don't
know some Republicans are still not sold
on Trump and I understand why a lot of a
lot of Republicans don't like him I like
the guy a lot but some some Republicans
don't like
him even the Republicans though who are
not sold on Trump seem to be sold on who
they will not vote for enter Rand Paul
who who says he has a major political
announcement to make with regard to 2024
it's not who he's going to endorse but
who he anti- endorses who he condemns
I've had a long relationship with Donald
Trump and there's a lot to like there
I'm also a big fan of a lot of the
fiscal conservatism of Ronda santis I
think V ramas Swami has been an
important voice also have listened to
and met with the independent Bobby
Kennedy I'm not yet ready to make a
decision but I am ready to make a
decision on someone who I cannot support
so I'm announcing this morning that I'm
never Nikki and if you go to never
nii.net you can let her know that you're
not supporter either I don't think any
informed or knowledgeable libertarian or
conservative should support Nikki Haley
I've seen her attitude towards our
invent our interventions overseas I've
seen her involvement in the
military-industrial complex $8 million
being paid to become part of the team
but I've also seen her indicate that she
thinks you should be registered to use
the internet that people posting ideas
anonymously I think she fails to
understand that our Republic was founded
upon people like Ben Franklin Sam Adams
Madison John Jay and others who posted
routinely for fear of the government
they posted routinely
anonymously Rand Paul's anti-
indorsement of Nikki Haley tells us two
things about the state of the GOP right
now in the 20124 race the first one is
Nikki Haley has to be the establishment
candidate she has to be the neocon
candidate she has to be the never Trump
candidate even if she were not so
inclined she would have to be that
candidate because that is her role in
the race that's the only Avenue
available to her but the second thing it
teaches us and this is something that is
a little bit weird and
surprising Donald Trump is a strangely
unifying figure on the right we'll get
to why in a second first though fellas
this is a no-brainer if you want to
protect your kids from the leftist
indoctrination that is rampant in the
mainstream media this is how you do it
start a 14-day free trial into bent key
this is the New Kids Entertainment app
from daily wire bent key is the only
streaming app that offers highquality
family-friendly shows that reflect your
beliefs bent key features amazing
characters and Timeless stories that
will spark your kids imagination and
curiosity with hundreds of episodes that
your kids will love and that you can
trust with new episodes streaming every
Saturday morning do you remember
Saturday morning cartoons well they're
back and they're better than ever but
don't take my word for it see for
yourself you can try bent key for free
for 14 days no catch no gimmick no
hidden fees just phenomenal content that
your kids will love and that you can
trust all you've got to do is use code
unlock at bent key.com you will get 14
days of unlimited access to Bent Key's
world of Adventure go to Bent key.com
use code unlock at signup to start your
trial
today
Rand Paul's anti- indorsement of Nikki
Haley shows that Trump is a weirdly
unifying figure on the right Rand Paul
is probably the most prominent
libertarian in National politics Mike
Lee has a a chance at that title
too Mike Lee has already endorsed Trump
Rand Paul is effectively endorsing Trump
because he's saying he's he'll he he's
not going to vote for Nikki he's never
Nikki and disantis right now has no path
to the nomination and christe's out of
the race I don't think Rand Paul would
like Christie very much and B's out of
the race so by
default that leaves that leaves this
Rand Paul as Trump's
guy but but Trump is also popular among
the not libertarian parts of the right
Trump is also pretty popular among the
traditionalists he's he's popular among
the post- Liberals he's you know it's
been said that obscure political
monikers are the right-wing version of
gender pronouns you know everybody's got
their own kind of weird version but the
the the part of the right that is I
think unfairly maligned as authoritarian
or more will let's put it in a nicer way
more willing to use state power I think
in line with the American tradition
those guys like Trump too Compact
magazine founded by S rabam Mari post
liberal Outlet says that Trump's the man
Trump still the guy for 2024 the
American post
liberal
another post- liberal and more
traditionalist type outlet they came out
and endorsed Trump the other day and
Trump gets the Libertarians here the
people that he doesn't get are the
establishment he doesn't get the Chamber
of Commerce he doesn't get the
interventionists who want to bomb every
country on
Earth or to put in a nicer way the
foreign policy Hawks he doesn't get them
he actually gets some of them because of
his tough talk and good track record on
Isis we're going to go kill Isis and he
did he destroyed Isis or the fact that
he took out Iran's top general or but
but in other ways he's kind of a dove so
the the people who are more skeptical of
intervention they can like him too you
know he he goes and says nice things
about Kim Jong-un or he says that we
need to stop intervening everywhere
overseas all the time and focus on the
American Homeland he he's a he's a
weirdly unifying candidate I don't again
you might hate him you but we haven't
seen a candidate able to unify the GOP
despite his Mean Tweets despite the the
Aida that he inspires in people we
haven't seen that in a very long time
now the establishment still does hate
him the head of the US Chamber of
Commerce Suzanne Clark has just come out
and implicitly but I think not so subtly
attacked Trump for his economic prop
proposals heading into
2024 let's be very clear in a global
economy and in fragile geopolitical
times it is in America's best interest
for other economies to grow and succeed
through free
markets prosperous nations are stable
Nations they become Partners allies and
ballasts against authoritarianism like
the free markets the global economy is
not a zero sum game someone else to does
not have to lose for us to win on the
contrary the rise of the rest means new
customers new markets and new allies for
us
okay what about
China is it true if if you're telling me
that it's always in our best interests
to open up new markets and tear down
barriers to trade and build up other
countries what about China we're on the
brink of World War II
xiin ping who I think has actually been
fairly responsible in his more
aggressive stance toward the US he said
as much just a month or two ago he said
look we don't want war but you got to
recognize this is about to be a bipolar
World China is on the rise our economy
is on the rise our national strength is
on the rise he's insinuating we are
going to take Taiwan we are going to
exert more influence around our country
and if you try to impede that we're
headed for war this is what the Harvard
political scientist Ram Allison refers
to as the thusi Trap that when a rising
power challenges a hedgemon 3quarter of
the time major conflict
ensues what does the head of the Chamber
of Commerce have to say to that well
yeah sure we might go to World War III
but we get a bunch of cheap electronics
from
China at the cost by the way of losing
our intellectual property because they
steal our IP and then rip off the
products and then when they have all of
our manufacturing it weakens us as a
matter of National Security and we
become very vulnerable and oh by the way
when China becomes really rich and buys
up all of our
debt it's much harder for us to maintain
our status as a global hedgemon we lose
a lot of Leverage to China what do you
mean you really think a rising tide
lifts All Ships all the time we always
need to reduce tariffs and Trump is the
big threat she's obviously talking about
Trump here because Trump broke with what
many people consider to be GOP Orthodoxy
which is that free trade is always great
Trump said no I want some more tariffs
Trump has gone much further in this
campaign and said he actually wants
mercantilism in the 21st
century and and Trump's been
inconsistent on this back in the 80s
he's got a a long-standing track record
of being in favor of tariffs but then
within the last 10 years he was
publishing op EDS I don't know if he
actually wrote them but they were
published under his name calling for
more globalization and but then he'd
also say we need more tariffs again and
we need more protectionism but then he
would sometimes say as president well we
want we we want to use tariffs as a
negotiating ships so that ultimately we
can get more free trade so that the
tariffs are really just a means to an
end and the end is more free trade but
then in 2024 he's come out and said no
actually the tariffs are good in and of
themselves so look the
guy like like all major politicians
doesn't have perfect philosophical
consistency here and people can try to
read the Tea Leaves of what he really
believes I think the record is clear he
is much more favorable to tariffs and
protectionism he's much more skeptical
of free trade than any Republican in my
lifetime but that's not throwing out our
principles as some of the modern
Republicans would have you believe
ironically Trump's position is much more
in line with the historical position of
the Republican Party the Republican
party was founded on tariffs Abraham
Lincoln the first Republican president
said give me a protective tariff I'll
give you the greatest nation on Earth
Earth it's it's not only e economic
nationalism and protectionism is not
only more in line with the historical
GOP which only adopted free trade in the
middle of the 20th century and it it
really only Rose to the four with the
presidency of Ronald Reagan who I will
mention instituted major steel tariffs
so even Reagan even St Reagan of of free
trade also was a protectionist when it
suited him but it but it's also in line
with the American tradition America was
founded on protective tariffs our
founding fathers were economic
nationalists or some of our our most
right-wing founding fathers I'm thinking
especially of Hamilton were very Pro
tariff
probably uh the GOP should take note I
guess the GOP voters have taken note
some of the interests of the GOP Chamber
of Commerce used to be allied with the
GOP they haven't taken note yet maybe
they should because the the happy
platitudes of the last 30 years don't
really hold up to the exigencies of of
2024 and they don't really hold up to
historical scrutiny either I'm not
saying that free markets are always bad
far from it I think free markets can be
a wonderful instrument for economic
growth but we don't want to let the Tail
Wag the Dog here okay we're not an
economy with a nation attached We're a
nation that needs to have a thriving
economy in order to remain strong and
vibrant but but the economy is there to
serve the political Community not the
other way around
speaking of trade Wars and
China China seems to be pretty bullish
on Trump's chances in 20124 the Chinese
state-run newspaper the global times
just came out and told the
world this was before the Iowa Caucasus
actually to quote prepare for the
possibility of Donald Trump being
reelected as president and you might say
well this is propaganda if you don't
like Trump you probably say see China is
pulling for Trump so they're not really
pulling for him they're just saying
there's a real chance the guy's going to
be reelected
and that might be the case foreigners
sometimes have a better sense of our
politics than we do I remember back in
2016 Vladimir Putin America's foe
Vladimir Putin came out and he he said
in in the early days of the primary he
said there's no question Donald Trump is
the leader in the Republican race and I
thought oh that's crazy propaganda or
he's just trying to get in our heads or
he's completely misreading the situation
this was back when all the really smart
people thought Trump didn't have a
chance but Putin was
right which makes sense I mean you'd
think that the dictator of a nuclear
reformer superpower might have a little
bit of insight into politics a guy who
came up as a KGB communist in the Soviet
Union he he probably understands a
little bit about politics probably more
than your average keyboard Warrior
pundit he was right and China might be
right here too the reason that
foreigners sometimes have better insight
into our politics than we do is the same
reason that you have great insight into
all of your friends problems don't you
you you have really really good Insight
me too we all we have really good
insight into all of our friends problems
and everything that they're doing wrong
and everything that they're missing but
we don't have quite as much insight into
our own problems do we no that's a
mystery we're befuddled by that put in a
pithier way and a more profound way
we're really good at seeing the in our
neighbor's eye we're not so good at
seeing the plank in our own eye and I
think that's what's going on here I
don't think China is running this
headline because they're really eager
for Trump to get back in the driver seat
don't forget before covid we were in the
midst of a trade war with China and we
were winning contrary to what the Smart
Set said would happen speaking of
problems happening in our families and
our communities jelly roll
who I don't really know anything about I
take it that he is a musician he has a
lot of face tattoos he's a really
interesting looking guy and he's an
interesting sounding guy uh Jelly Roll
Just testified before Congress
about the drug crisis overtaking the
country he's a former drug dealer
himself and the way that we talk about
that crisis and the way that we talk
about crime
broadly I also understand the Paradox of
my history as a drug dealer standing in
front of this committee but equally I
think that's what makes me perfect to
talk about this I was a part of the
problem I am here now standing as a man
that wants to be a part of the solution
I brought my community down I hurt
people I was the uneducated man in the
kitchen playing chemist with drugs I
knew absolutely nothing about just like
these drug dealers are doing right now
when they're mixing every drug on the
market with fentol and they're killing
the people we
love I'll be honest with y'all my desire
is to only get older and only do better
and be better I believed when I sold
drugs genuinely that selling drugs was a
victimless crime I truly believe that
y'all my father always told me what
doesn't get you in the wash will get you
in the rents now I have a 15-year-old
daughter whose mother is a drug addict
every day I get to look in the eyes of a
victim in my household of the effects of
drugs every single day and every single
day I have to wonder if me and my wife
if today will be the day that I have to
tell my daughter that her mother became
a part of the national
statistic what doesn't get you in the
wash will get you in the rinse I really
like that line I'm going to have to use
that line I think that's a great
Insight but the best Insight that jelly
roll has there is this term victimless
crime because first he he says you
know actions have consequences what
doesn't get you in the wash it get you
in the rinse today we think that actions
don't have consequences we think that we
will totally be uh immune to the logic
IC and natural consequences of our
actions there's there's a great meme
that was going around for a while and
the meme was Me
sewing yeah yeah this is awesome I love
sewing yeah yeah this is I love just
sewing and planting all these little
things and that me reaping o yikes how
did this happen yeah I don't want I
don't want to reap what I sew I just
want to keep doing all the sewing that's
really fun we know it we know this about
ourselves that we try to we do we try to
divorce I mean the clearest example is
in sex stuff we we divorce the end of
sex from the from sex itself but we do
we do it in everything man we do it in
everything now we
just I don't know if it's because of a
failure of long-term planning or because
of of a denial of logic I guess that's
probably what it is because in
logic things have consequences and we
deny logic these days and so we end up
with phrases and this is the key phrase
that jelly Ro used we we end up with
phrases like victimless
crime we people on the right use that
phrase especially the segments of the
right that that want to go squishy on
the social issues they say oh who cares
about a victimless crime do you hear
yourself do you hear that phrase that's
a that's a meaningless phrase because by
definition there can be no such thing as
a victimless crime we'll get to why in a
second first of my favorite comment
yesterday is from Bo elut who says how
is it summarized in 2 minutes if this is
a 49-minute video Mr
Davies they're on to
us they're on to all those videos that
we title such and such summed up in two
minutes and it's about 50 minutes isn't
it I'm not I'm not talking Mr D I don't
even have any ear piece in right now but
you're on to us that's true maybe look
the summary is 2 minutes and then you
get a little
extra you get 47 48 minutes of
extra I hate the phrase victimless crime
the libs use it the libs coined it the
libs popularized it of course but now
everyone uses it people on The Right Use
It Libertarians who argue
for the decriminalization of drugs or
prostitution or all sorts of weird
social stuff they say oh it's a
victimless crime we should stop Pro
there can't there's no such thing as a
victimless crime do you know where that
phrase comes from the phrase comes from
1965 the 1960s when many many bad things
were coined and popularized uh this is
one of them it was coined in an academic
paper by a guy named Edwin Shure and the
title of the paper was crimes without
victims deviant behavior and public
policy and and you know what his
examples are this is what comes after
the colon abortion homosexuality drug
addictions specifically drug addictions
exactly what jelly roll's talking about
says it's a victimless crime oh yeah
tell that to the parent who lost a kid
to drugs tell that to the many many
mothers and fathers in America right now
whose kids are dead because of Fentanyl
and drugs victimless crime not only are
the kids victims the parent the parents
are
victims the brothers the sisters the
whole political Community you kidding me
drugs are a victimless
crime it's one of the greatest examples
of victimization going on in our whole
country right now we have we have a a an
overdose epidemic that is so colossal
that basically everyone I think everyone
that I know knows someone or or know
someone who knows
someone who has died because of this
what about the other ones forget
homosexuality for a sec that'll be it we
talked about that enough on the show
yesterday two days ago abortion is a
victimless crime you murder a little
innocent baby that's a victimless crime
I don't think so and those are the best
examples they could come up with by the
way crazy because there's no such thing
as a victimless crime because a crime is
by definition an
injustice it's an act of violence
against someone can be an act of
violence against your neighbor it can be
an act of violence against the self it
can be an act of violence against Art
nature and God but it's an act it's
there's an injustice there there is a
victim there you
can't unless you just deny sin unless
you deny that anything is better than
anything else you know which I guess
some people do they don't really mean it
because they it's obviously nonsensical
the moment someone says there's no such
thing as Sin there's no such thing as
morality man the question I always ask
is oh yeah would you say it's better to
bake a pie for a widow than it is to
kick an orphan in the head and they look
at me they say oh that's a stupid
question why is that a stupid question
you have an answer for it the Smart Ones
among them they don't want to answer but
the answer yeah of course it's better to
bake a pie for a widow than it is to
kick an orphan in the head head okay so
if some things are better than other
things then there is a moral order and
there's good and there's
bad if you would if you would go so far
as to say it's a crime to kick an orphan
in the
head you you are describing that kind of
Injustice in political terms you're
describing you're describing
victimhood of
course now
this phrase if what doesn't get you in
the rinse will get you what doesn't get
you in the wash will get you in the
rinse this applies to a video that's
just gone
viral from the porn actress Mia Khalifa
don't worry you don't necessarily need
to take your children out of the room if
they're watching this right now it's not
it's not one of those videos this woman
goes viral all the time for political
reasons which I guess is better
than presumably her other videos on the
internet I don't know though actually
because the content of her political
activism is so awful that I I can only
imagine what her actual obscene content
looks like Mia Khalifa has gone viral in
this case not for her Pro terrorism
activism but because she was recounting
a very ugly incident that happened to
her at a restaurant here in her own
words and I get come up to by this guy
and his girlfriend and we were
interrupted in the middle of talking and
eating and he said hey M CIFA can I get
a picture with you and I looked up at
him and I'm like no we're eating and I
said it just like that like it was it
was a rude way but it was also very rude
for him to come up while someone was
actively in the middle of a conversation
and after I said that his girlfriend who
was standing next to him grabbed him by
the arm and said I told you that wasn't
her there's not enough on her face let's
go babe and I went into the bathroom and
cried and I didn't really know how to
handle it especially cuz it that came
from a woman and especially because I
was I like I was I was there for
business and it was something that had
nothing to do with the adult industry
and I was just very dejected and
embarrassed and felt like they they
would never want to work with me again
that must have been really I kind of
feel bad for Mia Khalifa here now
obviously every single person involved
in this story is just
terrible just everyone involved here is
doing something wrong and disreputable
but I I feel bad for it that's a really
nasty thing to I mean first of all as
she says it was the woman so think about
how many things had to go wrong for this
situation to take
place a guy would walk up to a porn
performer in
public and admit that he watches
pornography so degrading so creepy so
weird the guy would do it in front of
his
girlfriend and she's apparently okay
with it so weird so depraved so creepy
and then the girlfriend is the one who
makes the obscene comment at the porn
lady now Mia Khalifa admits she says I
was very rude to them they come up to me
they ask for a picture they're fans I
guess and they're willing to admit that
then I was rude to them that was wrong
she shouldn't do that if anyone is going
to come up to you and be nice to you and
compliment you in public you you ought
to be gracious about that that's a good
thing to do and then what they were rude
back to her and she was upset by this
because she felt shame
because they pointed out that she's a a
hooker and and they
described the shameful actions that she
boasts about and and publicizes and that
they are so U encouraging of that they
would that they would actually approach
this woman in public and talk about how
great it is but the moment that they
became hostile toward one another the
the
gal pointed out the shameful acts that
this girl does and the girl felt shame
for those shameful
acts what doesn't get you in the wash
will get you in the
rinse believe it or not even in the year
of Our Lord 2024 even in modern society
actions still have
consequences what she's really upset
about she says she's upset that a woman
would say this to her in public what
she's really upset about is the the
shame of prostituting herself and
degrading herself and and treating
herself she's a human being with a soul
made in the image and likeness of God
treating herself as nothing but flesh to
be transformed Med into glittering
pixels on a screen that can then be that
can then incite the lusts of men and
women apparently and and and become
fodder for other shameful sexual
acts that's what really bothers her but
she can't admit that even as she's
speaking openly and vulnerably about
this she she can't admit that we can't
admit in our culture that actions have
consequences so we're always
surprised we're always surprised when we
we reap what we sow and when we're
talking about
politics there's that great line from HL
Menin which is that democracy is the
theory that the common people know what
they want and deserve to get it good and
hard and we're shocked we're shocked
when the totally predictable results of
our
actions turn out to
be true wow shocking totally what what
what else did we expect H you know what
I expect I expect to see you tomorrow
I'm Michael nll this is the Michael N
show see you
[Music]
then